your name is Kennedy and you're
Republican hi I'm Nicole SP with reason
thank you for coming today for lunch
we're going to be interviewing MTV's
Kennedy she has not worked at MTV since
the second Clinton administration but as
we were just discussing at lunch she
will always be called MTV's Kennedy for
the rest of her life you've got a fan
already but Kennedy was one of the great
faces of 90s alternative culture not
simply because she was a high profile
personality on MTV and a variety of
other shows and then later before and
later radio shows but she was
alternative in a way that was not fully
appreciated in the 90s a great decade of
alternatives which is that she was a
non-democratic fawning liberal in the
media particularly among youth culture
which marked her as pretty much one of a
kind perhaps almost as much as her
turban today marks her as one of a kind
it's not chemotherapy right let's get
that out Turban important regard yes we
spoke before so that's one more thing
off my bucket list
but what we are and what's interesting
is that you'll never see it leave her
head until it's on mine it's a that's
quite a trek but what we're going to do
today is we're going to talk about
Kennedy's adventures as a radio
personality as a TV personality and also
as one of the highest profile
libertarians particularly on the west
coast and your I want to make sure that
I get your current gig correct because I
always forget the call letters of your
radio station with Kennedy with music in
the morning with MTV's Kennedy yeah
that's good okay so it's a big fight but
well let's talk about you know at MTV
you were kind of you became known kind
of as the House Republican I mean you
were you were out there you were having
fun
you were indistinguishable from the
other correspondents and other faces on
MTV except for this one glare I mean you
were distinguishable and that you had a
lot of energy and you were actually
funny but you were you know the same as
everybody else except you were a
Republican how did that how did that
come to public knowledge and you know
tell us a little bit about that well
it's interesting because when I was at
k-rock which is my competitor in LA
which is where I got my start and
broadcasting I was an intern and then a
DJ which was great because I would do
overnights and I'll need to overnight
radio shows that I would write poems and
so I had a poetry corner and a common
theme in my poems was my love for Dan
Quayle of course
so I had publicly proclaimed that and I
was also working as an intern on the
morning show and they they were always
delighted by my republican-leaning so I
never knew that it was a bad thing I
didn't go as there was an entire group
of people out there can you recite any
of the quelled sonnets my memory or
they're not suitable for and now that
I'm married I don't make those
proclamations in front of so many kind
of faces but so Kevin sent me to Little
Saigon where the Vice President was
visiting and I asked the last question
during a press conference which was mr.
vice president how do I look in purple
and he paused for a second and he said
you uh you look great in purple and it
infuriated all of the political
journalists in Southern California and
they were offended that their questions
were not taken I saw that as a minor
victory night I realized this was really
a way to upset people and well and then
flash word you were covering the Clinton
administration in the MTV studio when
either Bill Clinton or Al Gore as
candidates or as but you were at the
inauguration yeah you were a part of the
coverage and that's when your Republican
leanings deeply closeted worth thrust
into public view by what process well it
was interesting because I the 1993
inauguration was the most star-studded
party I had ever been to it was it was
though Etta James at last was being
played from every monument at full
volume people were so excited to have a
Democrat in the White House especially
and TV they were really emotionally and
politically invested in this candidate
because Bill Clinton's candidacy put MTV
News and Tabitha Soren on the map
because he was the first person who ran
for president who was really ready to
play ball and inside because Al Gore Al
and Tipper Gore had such a tight
relationship with popular music
that was over that was never mentioned
like this was it was a huge generational
ship that he was the first rock and roll
president embraced him and he embraced
them right back and there was something
like that 18 balls that night and to an
mtv through this gala and I'm not lying
it was literally like every you knows
like Tom Brokaw talking to Roberts Niro
and there's Sarah Jessica Parker and
Matthew Broderick and bar knows over
here and Jack Nicholson and it was crazy
my head was just spinning and I was so
excited because John McLaughlin was
there and so and he brought Martha
Stewart as a date and so he found the
lake Grove who at the time was a
columnist for The Washington Post and he
was like Lloyd Martha Stewart is my date
tonight
Lloyd I brought her this evening Martha
so I was looking in 1993 she was looking
good okay
so that was a big jail prison party this
is so pre prison yes so I was like you
know I'm I'm a Republican and I was
wearing this beautiful Pamela Dennis red
studded floor-length column gown with
the nicest dress that I've ever been in
in my life was worth thousands of
dollars and I had armed security to make
sure I didn't steal it and I
red suede Chanel platform shoes and and
so I lifted up my dress in the middle of
the thing and in Matthew Broderick and I
remember his eyes and I go first view
and his eyes got so big and and I showed
him my word no doubt showing him
something he had never seen so I had
gotten a Republican tattoo when I was 18
that Nick conveniently pointed out last
night looks like a pig that's why the
two children will do to a person see
that doesn't make any sense because the
tattoo wouldn't shrink besides so dark
so anyhow but only towards women anyhow
boy grove ended up he didn't write about
Martha Stewart he wrote about the woman
in the red dress from MTV who lifted it
up and embarrass John McLaughlin and
then John McLaughlin told the story on
The Tonight Show and then I was invited
on The Tonight Show and told the story
and then I was manatee fair and boy grow
be an article about me and Vanity Fair
and this I mean it was too much of a
mind warp your name is Kennedy in your
Republican and you're on MTV
so and then your later I mean so that
became part of your persona really is
that you were like a right-wing chick on
MTV I talked about too much on air but
there were times when if I was
interviewing bands and a couple of the
bands that I remember one was Marilyn
Manson and the other was Tom Morello
from Rage Against the Machine and for
those of you who know rage against the
machines music they there's no column
far enough left I mean they they
actually almost circle all the way
around to being Callista Gingrich like
that's happening it's it's impressive
and in Tom Morello made a snide comment
about me being Republican and I only got
into it with him about you know open
markets and and he did not like that at
all because they actually in in some of
their one of their CDs they have a list
of books like a photograph of book
spines and you know presumably like okay
simpletons this is what you should be
reading here is your education not only
music but life there wasn't a lot of
Reagan biographies know what now you did
you're kind of your other one of your
other big MTV political sports that you
wrote on pop dole's campaign bus Oh on
the plane or the bus yeah I mean there
was 96 hours to victory that's exam and
he slept what 92 of those hours no he he
and Elizabeth Dole have the most
incredible vibrant spirits and they were
both very very gracious and I found Bob
Dole to be very funny and charming but
he invited me on board like it was gonna
get him something like you know who's
gonna get a beating folks you know those
kids across America we're gonna tune in
to see you know to be like wow she's a
Bob
I think the the difference was marginal
but I was with the Oak Ridge Boys in Chi
Chi Rodriguez so you know I go Friday's
Puerto Rico so what what was the
network's reaction when you became known
as a Republican they were thrilled no
they actually were it was interesting
because some of my counterparts were off
hosting events for Planned Parenthood
and in various liberal organizations and
I remember I got a lot of grief for I
was given an auto him go speak at
Phyllis Schlafly as young Eagles and you
know I Washington DC and it was great
but they they were really upset about it
so they put a clause in my later
contracted MTV that said I was not
allowed to engage in any political
speech or promotion without written
consent from the network and you know
written consent from the network could
take days so if I called them the night
before and said good morning America
wants me to come on tomorrow and give a
young conservative rebuttal to the State
of the Union address and you know
conveniently there would be no one in
the press department to get back to me
with the written consent so and there
was no one else in the network who had
that and I was thought that was really
curious well you know one of the things
that's interesting and that is
particularly relevant to this audience
is that over time there you also realize
that you are not actually a Republican
or a conservative yeah talk a little bit
about how you came to an understanding
that you you know that you were actually
libertarian and why you didn't realize
it earlier well it's like thinking that
you're a fetishists or a dominatrix but
I didn't like hurting people I just
liked wearing leather corsets
and it was a really important
distinction for me because I remember
having a conversation with the editor
one of the editors from Spin Magazine
he's like you know you're we talked
about various views and what we agreed
on what we disagreed on and he's like
you're not a social conservative and in
that that pained me because I really
wanted to be on the bus like I wanted to
be a part of a group because I was
always such a misfit and you know he was
absolutely right and it was when Kurt
Loder took me out for dinner he took me
to chez Josephine in New York and Kurt
was always very very gracious and we
were at two completely different worlds
at MTV you know there was the news
department which you know they poured a
lot of money into it was it was taken
very seriously it was very well regarded
within the network and established a
name for itself outside of the network
and and then there was the production
side Wow and you know we were the BJ's
and we were in the back of snoops Hilty
and you know we were just there to look
pretty and keep the flow going and I'll
never forget when one of the mtv news
producers got in a fight with one of the
music producers of the studio because we
weren't finished with our stuff and the
producer the news producers like you're
just bleeding the videos it's like our
videos pays your salary like once when
we're going down the 7-eleven Slurpee
slide at the VHS that buys to have the
Zorn's jimmy tunes so Kurt Loder though
correctly yeah but Kurt was always so
cool to me he was always really really
kind from the moment I got there and I
was so intimidated by it because he's
very smart he's very dry he's so funny
but he's a tough nut to crack and and
people were genuinely afraid of him
because they knew if they said something
dumb that he would call them out and
just annihilate them and and so I just
assumed that he was some lefty New York
journalist and he took me out and he
gave me a copy of Ayn Rand's Objectivist
epistemology and that was my first foray
into libertarian ideology and thought
and and I honestly didn't know what it
meant to be a libertarian I just knew it
reading about it
made so much more sense and then you
know when you make a diagram of the
really confining left-right spectrum
it's so much more complex than that and
it really is so inconsistent and narrow
on both sides and then I really felt at
the time that both sides were being
flunked these extremes and the more
extreme people became in their political
thought the less logical they grow and
the more I learned about libertarianism
the more it it seemed to make total
sense with what I believed well talked a
little bit about you know how have your
libertarian beliefs been received you
know both you know at MTV and then
beyond are they more palatable to a
wider range of people or are they more
disturbing to more people well I think
in the late 90s especially it was really
you're either a conservative or liberal
you're a Republican or you're a Democrat
and and people were very happy to
pigeonhole you and so you know there was
no ad-hoc argument for what people had
already defined you as they would not
accept that so you know no one could
have entertained a libertarian notion
unless I had just left and moved to
Montana and a survivalist compound I
think you know that might have made them
look at things a little bit differently
and I found on the west coast it's
really great because people are
politically engaged in a different way
and there's a different spirit and I
felt like my parents always embodied
that because my parents left the comfort
of a corporate law job my dad's a lawyer
in Indianapolis and wanted to move
somewhere beautiful and start a new life
and they didn't have any friends and my
dad got a job and in Portland they had
visited there and literally drove the
family out in our station wagon and it
always gave me the sense that you know
life is an adventure and there's
something up there for you to create you
just have to have the spine and the
desire to do it so would you say that
you had always been a libertarian but
you didn't know that there was such a
thing yeah
I didn't really I mean I didn't have a
word for it I didn't have a frame of
reference for the way my beliefs
coalesce and I didn't know that there
are other people out there who felt the
same way and it was actually it was
funny because I was at that that Young
Eagles event and talking about various
things and the subject of drug
legalization came up and I was hiding
like drugs or bad good and then a
college student with the Cato pin came
up to me and and he was like no actually
there's there's a really great argument
for legalizing drugs and you know my
ears sort of picked I said Oh tell me
more good man because I just thought
that heroin and all these things were so
yucky and dirty and dirty smelly people
did those drugs and you will be true you
will be selling heroin outside later
gracious enough to give me some real
estate so that helped open up you know
the idea that there's a third or fourth
or fifth position out there yeah what
you you talked a little bit about before
about where your beliefs come from how
you know it do you think that
libertarian beliefs is is it an impulse
that you're born with or is it something
born out of experience or where does it
really funny because people who aren't
the Rotarians who don't understand it
are so quick to quantify it and so I've
been having this war all week with
atheists lefty atheists on on Facebook
because I have the audacity to say on
Bill Maher last week that atheism is a
religion and I believe that it is and I
will accept that I'm using that term and
a cool colloquial intuitive sense that
you know it is not epistemological II a
religion uh-huh but in the way that
religious people express themselves in
this country really not that different
from the way atheists express themselves
in this country and they're more than
happy to squash down your beliefs and
get very defensive very quickly and so
one guy wrote libertarianism is just an
adolescent fantasy it's like square
use of the car it was like no it's
actually not it's actually the logical
progression of an open mind and if you
take it to its fullest it would actually
be the most productive and beneficial I
was some of you will remember last year
I was on Real Time with Bill Maher as
well and I was happy in the wake of
Kennedy's parents on Twitter somebody
wrote Kennedy is the worst guest on Bill
Maher since Nick now if you were saying
that you know part hardly going us up to
the idea of experience and I kind of
do-it-yourself culture your husband
Dave has a was a professional or is
professional snowboarder and then he
came from a kind of like non-political
but hippyish culture in the Pacific
Northwest but then when he started his
own business
he suddenly started getting more
interested in libertarian ideas yeah and
he it's it's been really interesting
watching his progress and I can't speak
for him but he is so much more involved
with a political process now and he's
definitely a libertarian because he owns
a small business in Southern California
they make snowboards and it's not that
it's a bad place to make snowboards that
California is silly with mountains but
it's a really tough place to be in
manufacturing it's a it's a really
hostile state to have a manufacturing
business in small business and so that's
what he is found is that he really wants
the government to get out of the way
because they certainly have been no help
I mean the Small Business Administration
all that nonsense that you know and I
talked to about the the figurehead
douchebags on Bill Maher and it doesn't
really matter what party but they all
spout these platitudes about the small
business is the backbone of this country
it's like yeah but you're doing
everything you can by
in taxes and and forcing people to
insure their employees regardless of
whether or not their employees can
insure themselves and it's it's very
unrealistic it is it's the only word I
can use to describe it is hostile but he
still persevered and you know I talked
to a lot of people on talk radio in LA
and whenever the subject comes up about
people who own their own businesses they
were to leave they want to go to Nevada
they want to go to Washington State
where there is a more amenable climate
to people who want to live the American
dream but you also in previous
conversations you've touched the third
rail of libertarian politics which is
parenting yeah and you have apparently
come up with you know a lot of
libertarians and when I started at
Reason in 1993 my child was the first
person born and the kind of reasoned
staff orbit in about 10 or 15 years and
it had seemed to be that to be a
libertarian you had to eschew any
possibility of reproduction even if you
were a man who had occasional access to
women
and it you know but libertarian
parenting I've had more than I'm sure
everybody in this room has had some kind
of conversation where a couple years ago
I've had a Charles Krauthammer and we
always get these stories of like I was a
libertarian until dot dot dot and
Krauthammer said you know I was a
libertarian which that was the first lie
of the conversation but but you know
until I had a daughter and as if you
can't be a parent at a libertarian but
what is your take on libertarian
apparently well my take is you know it's
it's from a mom's perspective and and I
have two daughters you know and I look
around and groupthink starts in
preschool you know it's not something
that happens in college or later and
it's it's really important for me to
teach my girls that you know you have to
be kind you have to be inclusive you
have to respect other people but you
know don't allow people to bully you and
and so much when you have beliefs that
are not held by a vast majority of
people they will try and pull you they
will because if they don't understand
you they will criticize you and it's not
by trying to bring you into their camp
just because you are the other you are
different and you really have to stand
up for yourself and you know I I want
them to express their individuality I
want them to be autonomous and I want
them to be confident and you know I I
want them to be able to go out and not
feel that they have to spend $900 on a
handbag because you know what because
that's taking money away from you we
should point out that your children are
three and six your daughters so all of
the hard work is still ahead and I see
young woman in my neighborhood and
they've got miniskirts and boots and
which is just it's not
I think anesthetic is really important
and you have to value yourself but I'm
also I'm also super into survivalism and
you know I want my girls to be able to
walk home and always have treats and
know that they have to have water and
you know it's like moms are the the
pocketbook survivalist by the way it's
like all we see on Discovery Channel is
these hulking men and hemp vests you
know out there fashioning rafts out of
snakeskin but it's like moms are the
real survivalists and and I realized
this the more and more as we go along
because if you ask any woman to empty
out her purse right now she would be
able to keep most of the room alive
breath mints and lipgloss for two weeks
but the moms can MacGyver their way out
of just about anything now you told me
once that you were this was some years
ago before your rise to what you were on
MTV I'm forgetting but your first
internship in in LA you were denied
after you were accepted because you were
a Republican what would that happen now
or do you think it's libertarianism on
the rise among younger people or among
older people or does it seem to you to
have you know over the past 20 years is
it is it more of a recognizable position
and if so why is that is it a good thing
it's recognizable position I think part
of that is due to the economy and people
realizing that the right-left paradigm
isn't going to bring back jobs it's not
going to get the economy going and
certainly not the government we've seen
so many big government administrations
one after the other and it just doesn't
work so finally people are doing couple
things they're going issue by issue
because that's just the way people are
informing themselves and I think that's
a really good advent of talk radio and
talk radio really takes it drumming what
what it allows people to do is learn
about things because Adrian Moore was on
my radio show and we talked about
high-speed rail and how ridiculous it is
and
California's and I don't understand this
they they approve this bond measure for
nine million dollars now the the cost is
gonna be ninety billion
it's the did you really think the math
was going to add up number one and in in
the state where we are just screwed
blued and tattooed in every imaginable
sense we really need to be spending 99
billion dollars on high-speed rail with
all the problems we got I mean we got 99
problems so well why don't we open it up
for some questions and let's ron paul
alpha wait 99 billion for ron paul not
know he's not a problem but like my mom
and i this is a really good example my
mom isn't about democrat she will
volunteer for every Democratic candidate
she she works the polls she she's all
over the place and you know she loved
Bill Clinton my grandmother you know god
rest her soul but she had a signed
picture of Bill Clinton in her house and
she's Michael dr. Monica Lewinsky she
has such a short what she did to him
mee-mah how much did you have to pay for
that how many Social Security checks
today today for her to afford that but
she but now your mom yeah my mom is is
this good but there's we agree on a lot
of Ron Paul stuff because she my mom
hates corporations and she she doesn't
like Wars and she doesn't like big
government so this this Ron Paul
character is really starting to sound
like a rational approach to these modern
political crises all right well thank
you
thanks very much that was great both of
you now that Dan Quayle is a
card-carrying member of the AARP who who
is your current crush on or more serious
very valid question and the answer is
Mitt Romney sons you want them to be
your brother wives yes exactly
turnabout is fair play are there
political figures out there that you
admire who you'd like to see go places
no I really I really do like Gary
Johnson and I was fortunate to meet
governor Johnson at a reasonable and I
have so much respect for what he's done
in New Mexico and I was surprised how he
was marginalized in the the Republican
debates and Gary and I are both
triathletes and now we both have celiac
disease so there's a not just that
legalizing narcissism that draws you
closer to you know make you say that but
my humility is probably my greatest
afternoon